Musik Ihr merkt, wir sind zu dritt. Wow! Eigentlich sind wir zu fünft hier heute da. Wir haben nämlich die Entourage von niemand geringerem als Riggedy Rockstar heute. Von Radio Fucking Nucular. Nein. Dem erfolgreichsten Podcast der Welt. Und reichsten Podcast der deutschen. Dem reichsten Podcast der Welt. Wie viel verdient ihr momentan auf Patreon? Ich glaube, drei, acht. Damit meinst du dreitausend achthundert Euro, was du gerade versucht hast. Ja, man redet nur noch so in so kurze, drei, acht. Dreitausend achthundert Euro für drei Leute. Das ist eine Menge, das ist schon ganz geil. Davon kann man sich schon mal was kaufen. Und was kauft ihr euch davon? Weil wir haben nämlich gemerkt, wir finden es eigentlich eine Frechheit, Geld zu verlangen von Leuten, weil wir haben zum Podcasten brauchst du halt nur zwei Mikros und ein Interface und wir haben alle schon und wir brauchen uns auch nicht in eine bessere Ausführung, das heißt wir können das Geld nicht wieder eininvestieren. Ja, aber das ist so geil, dann kann man sich geile Sachen kaufen, Klamotten und Autos. Aber man will ja den Hörern was zurückgeben, oder habt ihr das komplett abschaffen? Nee, wir kriegen ja den Podcast, das reicht doch. Versuchst du gerade, ihm ein schlechtes Gewissen zu machen, obwohl... Ja, du versuchst das gerade, versuchst du, mich so ein bisschen... Ich versuche, um ihm mein Schicks Gewissen einfach auszureden, indem mir der Radionukulameister gerade einfach sagt, ja, man kann mit den Leuten einfach so umgehen. Weil ich will das ja auch, ich will auch Geld einfach, aber... Aber die Leute machen das ja freiwillig, die können ja trotzdem deinen Scheiss hören. Ich meine, das hören dann irgendwie, wenn dann, wenn dann, ich weiß nicht, hunderttausend Leute hören und es sind aber nur so tausend, zweihundert, die sagen so, sie haben Bock, so was zu spenden. Aber die sind ja freiwillig da, die sind ja nicht gekommen, weil wir gesagt haben, macht das bitte so, wir brauchen neue Autos. Wir sind schon die Guten in der ganzen. Möchtest du eigentlich Rockstar genannt werden? Nee, sag doch bitte Max. Max. Das ist immer so schwierig, bei Leuten, wo man hauptsächlich den Künstlernamen kennt,
weiss man nicht mehr, wie man die ansprechen soll.
Irgendwie so Prince oder so weiss man auch nicht genau.
Ist es dann Herr Prince oder Mr Prince oder Prince?
Die Sache hat sich glücklicher, endlich.
Gott sei Dank ist er gestorben, bevor ich ihn unangenehm ansprechen konnte.
Aus dieser Awkward-Situation. Er hat es nochmal gut gemacht, aus Awkward-Situationen rauszukommen.
Das konnte er immer ganz gut. Er war einfach sterben.
Erstmal wollte ich euch allen, auch Larissa Ries, die hier im Raum ist und ihr Hund Wilma, der eben geniesst hat, erstmal wollte ich euch allen einen frohen Leichnam wünschen. Ja, alles gut. Einen frohen Leichnam. Dankeschön. Dir auch, Larissa. Warum gibt es das eigentlich? Die Diskussion hatte ich vor ein paar Tagen mit einem Freund. Ich habe eben nachgelesen, wie der Name entstanden ist und es hat weder mit fro Froh noch mit Leichnam was zu tun. Das heißt, es hätte auch einfach irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, Tötet eure Kinder Tage essen können. Es hätte genauso gut einfach noch viel schlimmer ausgehen können. Es wäre ein Tag, der hätte mich motiviert. Und woher kommt das dann? Kilo Darlings. Das habe ich nicht weiter gelesen. Irgendwann habe ich den Wikipedia-Artikel abgebrochen. Er war dröge geschrieben. Kill your darlings bedeutet, töte deine Kinder. Ehrlich gesagt. Ich finde aber auch, Wikipedia macht es falsch, weil die am Anfang die wichtigsten Informationen raushauen, man hat nicht mehr so viel Interesse, das weiterzulesen, weil die am Anfang schon die ganzen geilen Facts raushauen und am Ende kommt dann nur noch so, ja, okay, die Spannungskurve vom Wikipedia-Artikel, das ist, glaube ich, ein Thema. Du hast ja auch einen Wikipedia-Artikel, habe ich gesehen. Ja, habe ich tatsächlich. Ich habe mich intensiv darauf vorbereitet. Ich habe mich selber noch nie so richtig gelesen. Aber du, also... Ist das eigentlich eine Socke über deinem Mikrofon? Ja, mein Gott, das ist eine Socke. Ist der beste Pop-Shirt aller Zeiten, also wirklich, also auch im übertragenen Sinne, ist perfekt. Weil es ist gut, ist es mobil, kann man gut rumtragen. Aber du hast ja einen Wikipedia-Antrag schon mal bearbeitet, oder? Ich habe noch nie, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das geht. Du hast sogar eine Diskussion. Ich hatte eine Diskussion. Er ist mit Christian Görend und Dominik Hannes Teil, Hammes, Teil des 23. bestehenden Rudi Nukunna, sowie 19. Jahrhundert. Ja, ist nicht so spannend, die Diskussion. Ich dachte, ähm... Es gab mal irgendwann... Ich habe nur mal mitbekommen, dass einer gesagt hat von diesen... Da gibt es ja so Admin-Cidas... Ich verstehe das gar nicht, wie die Hierarchie ist bei Wikipedia, wer da was zu tun hat. Und da gab es mal einen, der hat gesagt, dieses ganze Podcasting ist nicht wichtig. Und da ging es dann halt im Internet rund, weil die ganzen sind so, was ist das nicht wichtig? So, es wurde dann halt wegen fehlender Wichtigkeit. Hier, fucking 3800 Euro wichtig. Ja, so weißt du, da sitzt irgendwo so einer so, hallo, ich bin der Mau, ich muss was tippen. Und dann war so eine Wikipedia-Mau. Und da war ich, das hat dann... Ich glaube, da war einfach sauer. Welche unwichtigen Leute entscheiden, was wichtig ist und was nicht bei Wikipedia. Welche Niesengeschöpfe. Am Ende ist es ein Buch, Alter. Ich wollte auch für die Sendung, die wir hier produziert haben, meint es das Deutsche SNL, die... Die unwahrscheinlichen Ereignisse, 23.80 Uhr, irgendwann im WDR. Mega egal. Die erste negative Quote im deutschen Fernsehen. Aber es war ganz einfach Spaß gemacht, das zu produzieren. Und darum geht es ja letztendlich eigentlich. Darum kommt es ja an. Und dafür wollte ich eine Wikipedia-Seite erstellen und dann auch so die Namen der ganzen Song-Mitglieder. Und dann hieß es ja, ja, die sind unbedeutend und unwichtig gelöscht. Das ist so schlimm. Und dann ist es auch einfach so zwei richtig negative Wörter, die man so reingedrückt bekommt. Man sitzt da so, hallo, ich stecke da meine Arbeit rein, du Wichser? Ja, aber es ist aber eine interessante Frage, ab wann man Wikipedia würdig ist. Aber du hast es anscheinend geschafft, wie hast du es geschafft, was hast du gemacht? Ich habe ganz, ganz viele Anläufe gab es anscheinend so. Es gab immer wieder Fans, aber einer hat mal so den Mega-Moe, er ist aus Rottkau, und er hat so einen ganz schlimmen Artikel, der wirklich wie er von einem Fünftklässler geschrieben war. Und er war ja nett gemeint, aber es es war wirklich ganz drauf. Ich war glücklicher, als er gelöscht wurde. Aber warte mal kurz, ein Album von dir war auf Platz 37 der deutschen Charts? Ja. Aber dann hast du ja, also erst mal Applaus und dann hast du ja wirklich aber auch so einen Artikel verdient, wahrscheinlich. Weil wenn man da schon so eine Tabelle bekommt, dann muss ja irgendwer sich hingesetzt haben, wo so eine HTML-Scheiss geschrieben haben. Oder ist das einfach, aber wirklich weder, ich weiß es nicht. Keine Ahnung. Aber schon geil. Aber Platz 7 und 30 war ganz toll. Hättest du die Rückblicken eher Platz 36 gewünscht? Ja. Ich bin in der Woche rausgekommen, da auch eine neue Helene Fischer-Platte rausgekommen wurde. Geht natürlich alles an. Und Jan Delay. Und Jan Delay und es war Ostern. Das war glaube ich die schlimmste. Also das Label hätte nicht falsch liegen können. Also man hätte nur so noch am Weihnachtswochenende releasen können, um noch mehr abzukacken.
Welchen Platz hätte es denn verdient?
Ach so, Top 20 hätte ich schön gefunden.
Ja, ist ja schön.
Ja, 18?
18 super!
Ja?
Ich finde es immer so geil, wenn es irgendwie so Top-Listen gibt, wo man dann sagt, das Plattenlabel versucht zu beschönigen, welchen Platz man gemacht hat, und dann sagen die, er hat es in die Top 18 der deutschen Schingel zuerst geschafft, wo man sofort weiss, welchen Platz er hatte, weil wenn es Platz 16 gewesen wäre, hätten sie vielleicht Platz in die Top 16 gesagt. Also instant ist es da Platz 18. In einem Wikipedia-Artikel steht auch, dass du 2005 dein erstes Freestyle-Battle gewonnen hast. What? Das fand ich ... Das war auch das letzte Mal, dass ich gefreestyled habe. Mach mal einen Beat an. Mach mal jetzt ein Beat. Nein, nein, nein. Okay. Freestylen finde ich das Schlimmste auf der Welt. Aber da hat derjenige, den Wikipedia-Titel geschrieben hat, gemerkt, so da ist seine Karriere begonnen. So, das war der erste Punkt der Karriere. Stimmt, geil. Es gab ja noch eigentlich vorher einen Punkt, wo ich mal im Quatsch Comedy Club versagt habe. Ehrlich? Will ich auch Stand-Up? Stand-Up. Ohne Gimmicks, ohne Piano, ohne ... Kannst du dich noch an einen Gag erinnern? Tatsächlich gar nicht mehr. Nicht mal einen? Ich glaube, ich bin auf die Bühne ... Ich habe eigentlich das Kristallprinzip versucht damals. Ich war seiner Zeit schon weit voraus, weil da seine Augen zusammenliegen. Ich habe gesagt, ich bin rausgekommen, ich bin der Max, ich bin fett, glaube ich, da war schon Husten im Raum. Es war auch einfach ein Mann als Heubeilen verkleidet durchgelaufen, weil es so schrecklich war. Durchgerollt, Kristall wahrscheinlich. Kristall so, den merke ich mir. Da war das, ja da war. Aber ich finde es geil, wenn deine Karriere fängt an, Rockstar gewann 2015, sein erstes Freestyle-Battle in Aschaffenburg. Geil, geil. Aber das war mein 8-Mile-Moment. Er war der einzige Teilnehmer leider. Das war mein 8-Mile-Moment, Alter. Ein Jugendcafe, 200 Leute gehen rein, 300 waren drin, die Luft stand, die Leute sind über die Fenster im Klo reingeklettert und ich stand da oben und war meine, weißt du, ich sah halt aus wie der Dorf Eminem, der Dorfmo. Und hab die ganzen Typen, die alle irgendwie so in dieser Savage-Phase waren, wo sie die Kappen so getragen haben, so S-R-V, so wie Hunde, und einfach nur wie Hunde gerappt haben. Die Kappe runtergezogen. Mhm, die haben immer so, ja genau, die haben immer so... Bis auf die Nase herunter. Saras hat immer noch nichts gesehen, glaube ich. Und hat dann nicht gesehen, wie scheiße er damit eigentlich aussieht. Und auf jeden Fall kam ich dann da rein mit so einem Wollpulli und hab dann damals dieses Freestyle-Battle da abgehalten und hab dann da alle nach und nach an die Wand gefickt, obwohl alle dachten, was ist das für ein komischer Typ mit seinen komischen Klamotten und so? Aber wir machen ja auch manchmal Freestyle. Mach dir.
Und ja, wir üben das immer.
Und wir haben uns gefragt, hast du eine Line, mit der du anfängst, irgendwie so einen Reim, mit dem du dann drin bist?
Weiß ich nicht mehr, ich habe ja seit zehn Jahren nicht mehr gefreestyled.
Und da hast du einfach alles dann verdrängt, was du davor gemacht hast.
Ich habe, ich habe...
Mein Name ist Rockstar, das Rock steht für...
Stein.
Rocksteine.
Harte Stern.
Leim.
Kein. Fein. Stein. Hör auf, ja, ich höre, hör auf, Entschuldigung. Ich finde es auch so ein bisschen absurd, dass sich diese Hip-Hop-Welt, die ja so krasse Typen, krasse Gangster dann so mit Lyrik überschneidet irgendwie. Ja, reimen vor allem. Ich finde das immer so seltsam, warum hauen die sich nicht aufs Maul, warum hat sie das durchgesetzt, dass man, dass man, wer schreibt die besseren Gedichte? Also das ist ja wirklich so dermassen konterintuitiv, also das ist ja so seltsam, wenn man irgendwie wenigstens Kampfsport oder Skateboard oder Breakdance vermisst, aber dann sagt man das Gedicht, das schwulstmögliche, was es gibt eigentlich in der Denkweise, zu sagen, man schreibt die cooleren Gedichte. Was ist da passiert? Dass gerade sowas dann irgendwie so eine Battle-Philosophie dann ans Tageslicht gebracht hat. Ich meine, die hätten ja auch Theater spielen können, einfach so eine kleine Szene. Sind wir vor, so Azad und Massiv machen so gegeneinander Theater. Ja, so ein Auftritt und dann so ein Limerick oder sowas. Limerick. Ich glaube, dein Hund lechzt nach Freiheit. Soll ich ihn hier rauslassen? Ich weiß nicht, ob er die Kabel da anbricht. Nein, nein, ich glaube, es ist ... Ja, dann lassen wir ihn lieber einfach in Gefangenschaft, hier in dieser stickigen Tonbox. Wo sehr viel Schokolade auf dem Boden war, habe ich verteilt. Es ist nicht deine Schuld, aber Hunde gehören einfach ins nichts Büro, es tut mir leid. Leute werden sich fragen, warum Larissa Ries zum ersten Mal hier bei uns in der Nähe ist, während einer Aufnahme und wir sie ja nicht das Mikrofon lassen. Aber jetzt ist der Knallallrad durch, weil wir haben Rockstar eingeladen, der Series ist ein lästiges Anhängsel gerade einfach und wir werden den einfach jetzt Knall halt ignorieren. Nein, aber du bist natürlich auch noch Gast. Ja, halt small. Wir hatten sehr lange keine Gäste mehr, aber wir wissen gar nicht warum, aber jetzt haben wir uns mal wieder getraut, einen Gast einzuladen. Wir haben die Gelegenheit der... Der war der Letzte? Der Letzte? Ralf Rute? Donny O'Sullivan. Donny O'Sullivan. Donny O'Sullivan. Sag bei X. Einer der grossen drei Podcaste Radio-Nukular, Podcast UFO und Gäste Liste Geistermann, die drei grossen Podcasts Deutschland. Ach, der ist bei Gästen Liste? Ja. Ich habe immer noch das auf dem Stream wegen Buckelberg. Buckelberg. Buckelbergsberg, Buckelsberg, von Buckelsberg, der mit den grauen Haaren von Gästeliste, die Geisterbahn. Die gehen auch inzwischen auf Tour, ne? Wir? Nein, nein, ihr noch nicht.
Ne, wir nicht, wir haben uns was Besonderes überlegt, wir wollen eine Inkognito-Tour machen, dass wir auftreten, aber nicht als wir selbst, sondern als Undercover-Zauberer-Team, weil ich finde die Live-Tour immer mega geil, ich habe es auch total
genossen bei euch, aber es ist halt schon
ein recht leichtes Publikum. Das ist jetzt
keine Kritik oder so, aber die kennen halt
die Insider, die finden die sowieso geil,
die haben sowieso Bock und da kann man
irgendwas sagen und die feiern das so oder so
oder wenn man sich mal verspricht, ist es A, dann ist es halt
der Max, der Dusselige.
Nicht bös gemeint, aber es ist halt sehr
relativ einfach. Nicht, dass ich das nicht
respektiere und mega Respekt davor habe, was ihr da abgezogen
habt, aber ich fände es auch mal geil,
Das war es für heute. Max, der Dusselige, nicht blöds gemeint, aber es ist halt sehr relativ einfach. Nicht, dass ich das nicht respektiere und mega Respekt davor habe, was ihr da abgezogen habt, aber ich fände es auch mal geil, wenn man das einfach von einem komplett neuen Publikum, die nichts kennen, die keinen Insider kennen und gar nichts und vielleicht einfach 20 Jahre über dem Durchschnitt sind und irgendwie was ganz was anderes ist. Und dann da kommen mit Floppen einfach, komplett Fällen einfach, gar nichts. Zauber-Show oder sowas, dann Borentin und Beffan machen die grosse Zaubershow und dann, dass Leute hinkommen, die wollen wirklich Bock auf Magic haben und dann machen die da einfach unseren Podcast und die haben keinen Bock mehr und gehen. Einfach unkommentiert setzen wir uns da raus und machen unseren Podcast. Oder einfach in ein Altersheim gehen und den während die Mittagessen machen. Die müssen zuhören. Einfach jetzt dann genau, in denen sie reingeschoben werden von den Pflegern. Oh, da fällt mir gerade eine ganz, ganz schlimme Geschichte ein. Wir mussten mal so, haben so Schultheater aufgeführt und dann wurde irgendwann so, ja, wir wollen den alten Leuten was Gutes tun, wir führen das nächste Woche nochmal im Altersheim in Rotka auf, in Rotka und Niederroden. Und dann sitzt du da und du spielst dann da dein Programm runter und du merkst einfach so, die werden da so reingeschoben, die wollen da nicht sein. Die können aber auch nicht fliehen. Die können nicht fliehen, die sind immer so, helf mir hier. Ich stelle mir vor, dass Altersheimer einfach die Entertainment-Hochburgen sind, so die achte Klasse geht und so zwei sibirische Tiger werden reingefahren, irgendwie so die mega, so die Monster Truck Show und so einfach die alle Leute den ganzen Tag am Entertainment Overkill einfach sitzen, der ganze Zeit. Interessen sie aus. Ganz große Superstars, Whitney Houston tritt trotzdem noch mal auf, mit Prinz Hand und Handel. Die warten alle vor der Tür, so einfach so Prince, irgendwie Mick Jagger oder so, stehen alle rum. Alle Bock und ... Weil das kann man ja nicht ablehnen eigentlich, so alter, kann es ja nicht ablehnen. Nee, kann man nicht ablehnen. Könnt ihr Sachen ablehnen? Wie ist das immer so, wenn sie sagen, ich bin sehr krank und ich will euch nochmal interviewen oder so? Schwierig, du lehnst bestimmt auch ab und zu Sachen ab, so ne? Ja, man muss ja, man muss halt irgendwas kommen und so. Wir wurden jetzt angefragt für ZDF, die einen Beitrag über Podcast machen wollen, und wir wollten eigentlich ablehnen, weil wir, man sieht es halt genau, dann stinke ich mit der Kamera und wir nehmen so awkward auf. Das ist ein awkwarder Risser-Moment, das ist halt einfach ein seltsamer Moment, wo man hier einfach ungefragt an die ist und dann versucht, uns aufzunehmen und dann eigentlich will man das macht auch, natürlich nimmt man das nie echt auf und man faket das so. Und dann muss man halt diese schwierigen O-Tin an die Kamera geben. Ja, ich bin Stefan, ich will machen das jetzt seit zwei Jahren. Das passt einfach auch gar nicht so. Das ist irgendwie auch, ich weiß nicht, ja es geht ganz schwierig. Vor allem diese Berichte sind ja meistens auch nicht so geil gemacht. Ich war irgendwann mal bei RTL, da wollten sie Rockstar vorstellen. Ach du liebe Zeit, aber RTL Hessen. Weil das war damals für den New Music Award und da war ich für... Dein RTL. Mein RTL, das war wirklich mein RTL. Nein, nicht dein RTL, das RTL von Hessen. Unser RTL. Und wir waren dann da, wir hatten so einen richtig beschissenen Proberaum in so einer Schweinescheune irgendwo hinten drin, und dann kamen die RTL-Mongos da an. Das passt ja, haben manche, woher gesagt, die euch nicht mögen. Ja, aber das doch zu rdl, in dem haben sich das ja richtig wohl gefühlt, die haben auch gleich drei von den Schweinen mitgenommen für mitten im Leben und so. Dann standen sie und dann, ja, könnt ihr nochmal mehr so Acting und auch immer so, ja, du kennst Crow, ja, ich kenn Crow, scheißegal, dass ich Crow kenne, ja, kennst du auch Kraftklub, ja, erzähl mal was von Kraftklub, ich bin doch hier, um über mich zu reden, du Arschloch, so. Und dann habe ich halt immer gesagt, mach ich nicht, so. Dann haben die sich mega da eingepisst und so. Kannst du nichts über Crow erzählen, wie sieht der ohne Maske aus? Der ist ja wie ein Mensch, Alter. Nee, der ist echt ein Panda. Ah, du kennst wirklich Crow? Die waren mit dem auf Tour, ja. Ah. Jetzt würde ich auch gerne darüber reden, aber ich will nicht den RTL Hessen-Moment jetzt hier haben. Sei nicht mein RTL. Ist Scraw eigentlich Banksy? Weiß man da was? Ja, ja. Wir haben überlegt, dass wir, wir haben irgendwann gemerkt, dass beim Neomagazin schreiben wir manchmal Fragen, die Jan aber nie interessiert, aber einfach so backup-mässig, schreiben wir dann für ihn die Fragen auf. Wir haben irgendwann gemerkt, dass es niemand liest und wollen dann immer die Frage oben hinschreiben, bist du Banksy? Weil wir dachten, statistisch gesehen ist bei dem 395. Gast vielleicht irgendwann mal die Chance relativ groß, dass es Banksy ist. Ja, aber irgendwann sagt Herbert Feuerstein einfach ja. Ja. Ich bin bei uns. Herbert Feuerstein ist motherfucking Banksy. So, what? Er muss auch ja. Das ist die Regel bei Banksy. Die Regel bei Banksy ist, er muss ja sagen, wenn er gefragt wird. Wie bei Cops. Das ist wie bei Undercover-Polizisten, die müssen dann ja sagen. Ist das so? Nein, das ist auch nur eine Urban Legend. Wie Banksy in die Welt gesetzt hat wahrscheinlich einfach. Das ist so mein Fuck. Die Undercover-Polizisten in die Welt, das stimmt, ist eigentlich viel cleverer, zu sagen, dass Undercover-Polizisten das nicht sagen müssen. Das sagen müssen, weil dann kann jeder Undercover-Polizist immer sagen, nein. Und dann denken alle, okay, es ist kein Polizist sein. Hat vor Gericht aber trotzdem noch Bestand, das ist total clever. Ja, clever. Hast du auch clevere Ideen manchmal? Nein, ich bin Rapper, die haben keine cleveren Ideen. Ne, ich habe ja immer clevere Ideen, ich bin ja fleissig. Aber jetzt gerade aktuell, ich hatte vor ein paar Tagen eine Sonne, ich habe es vergessen. Soll das eine Sonnenbrille? Nein, nicht eine Sonnenbrille, ich hatte eine total klare Idee, wie man alles auf der Welt verändern kann, ich hab's vergessen. Nein, Alter, das kann man nicht sagen, das ist doch nicht ernst. Es war wirklich so, wo ich dachte, huiuiuiui, und dann war das weg. Dass du dich selber überrascht hast. Ja, ich bin selber überrascht, dass im Auto ein geile Moment kam. Das hat man manchmal auch, da vergisst man es, weil einem einfall, dass man noch Milch braucht oder sowas. Diese Scheissmähl, Mollochmilch. Da denke ich mir auch, wenn man die ganze Zeit essen müsste, schlafen müsste und so einen Scheiss. Diese ganzen Sachen, die man einfach braucht, wenn man lebt, existiert. Ja, wenn man das einfach mal abschafft. Genau. Wir schlafen nicht mehr und wir essen nicht mehr. Ich glaube, wir schlafen zwei Drittel unseres Lebens, 20 Prozent unseres Lebens. Ich habe das die Zahl parat gehabt, als ich mir eine Matratze gekauft habe, weil ich den Verkäufer beeindrucken wollte, aber jetzt werde ich mich da weiter vergessen.
Aber er hat es tatsächlich auch nicht geschafft, ihn zu beeindrucken. Er hat die Line gedroppt und er so, ja, kann sagen. Weiss ich, ich bin Matratzenverkäufer, du Arsch. Und er stand auch in dem Laden einfach auf jedem Werbestell, sie verbringen so und so viel Stunden ihres Lebens mit Schlaf, also schlafen sie besser gut. Ne, aber wenn man das alles nicht mehr machen müsste, wenn man nicht mehr essen müsste, aufs Klo gehen müsste, im Stau stehen, diese ganzen natürlichen Dinge, die man halt im Leben durchlebt, das wäre echt geil, glaube ich, das wäre echt ein besseres Leben. Dann kommst du auf bessere Ideen vielleicht einfach. Du hast ja mehr Zeit. War das deine gute Idee, vielleicht nicht mehr schlafen zu müssen? Nee. Schlaf ist schön. Schlaf ist super gut. Ich schlaf ganz gern, aber ich schlafe letzter Zeit super kurz so durch. Ich bin so ein Fünf-Stundenschläfer geworden. What?! Ja, geht mir aber auch so. Ich bin heute auch irgendwie nach sechs Stunden aufgewacht, konnte nicht mal einschlafen, weil dann war es hell und dann sind so Kinderidioten draußen auf dem Spielplatz und so, und die haben überhaupt keinen Respekt mehr heutzutage. Kinderidioten. Also nicht nur Kinder, es waren auch dumme Kinder. Als wär's ein Begriff einfach. Schwarzleibigen Fallen. Also Kinderidiot. Das waren so Infanten einfach. Das war gar nichts. Infant ist auch ein geiles Wort. Ja, das hat mein Deutscher, der Karl-Lehrer, mal gesagt. Als du irgendwie gerade sowas bearbeiten musst, dann stand er so am Fenster und hat auf den Sportplatz rausgeschaut und da haben gerade so Kinder Fussball gespielt und die einen hatten so schwarze Trikots und dann stand er nur so da, schwarzleibige Infanten. Bad. Mit der grösstmöglichen Verachtung so. Mit Sport kann da nichts anfangen und mit Kindern auch nicht, die lesen auch nicht Goethe, so das schwarzleibige in Fakten. Leibige, schwarzleibige. Das war so und also nur so, what the fuck, Alter, das ist ein krasser Typ. Hat er aber die Hände auf dem Rücken gehabt, wenigstens. Ja klar, so richtig in dem Rücken, so auf der Gürtellinie, so einfach. So leicht grinsinsend finde ich, das ist genau mein Stil. Ich glaube, so Deutschlehrer werden vielleicht sogar die besseren Freestyler dann manchmal einfach. Weil sie Deutsch können. Weil sie Deutsch sehr gut können, ja. Die kennen alle Worte. Die kennen Host, Host, probier doch mal Maus. Jambus reimt sich auf Bambus, Mic drop. Bam. Ja, die kennen einfach Wörter, die man nicht so kennt. Kennst du diese Geste, wenn man manchmal Nein sagt und sich dabei so ins Hohlkreuz legt? Nein, was? Nein? Nein, nein, nein, nein, so wenn jemand sagt so, ey, und dann war ich auf Ibiza und weißt du, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, aber dann wirklich so, gibt's ja nicht. Vor allem, ich frage mich ja, was das für eine komische Geste ist, dass man sich so ins Hohlkreuz legt und manchmal auch so wirklich mit den Armen zu stützen. Nein, das ist doch. Also das will man wirklich so zeigen. Aber das ist auch beim Lachen manchmal, wo man so, haaa, und dann nach vorne wieder. Ja, das stimmt auch, aber wirklich so dieses, dieses so, als würde man gleich… Aber dann ist es immer kein ehrliches Lachen. Wenn man im ganzen Körper lacht, ist es nicht ehrlich. Wie sieht denn ehrliches Lachen aus?
Da macht man nicht so...
Das ist...
Lachen ist wie Orgasmus, das musst du fühlen.
Das kannst du nicht täuschen, das merkt man.
Woran denn? Woran merkst du ein kürziges Lachen?
Also es gibt einfach Leute, da weiss sie, lachen einfach nur, weil sie lachen müssen jetzt.
Okay, auf drei lacht einer von uns echt und einer von uns unecht.
Und du musst rausfinden, wer echt lacht und wer nicht, okay? Drei, zwei, eins. Das war natürlich das echte Lachen, weil du hast wesentlich weniger gestikuliert. Er hat völlig übertrieben. Er hat das nicht gesehen, er hat sich überschlagen dabei. Leider zeigt er einen Schlagabfall. Ich liege jetzt auf dem Boden. Ganz schlechtes Timing eigentlich. Hast du schon mal einen Orgasmus vorgetäuscht, Larissa Ries?
Ach Gott, was sind das denn diese Fragen hier?
Ja, aber eben. Ich dachte mir einfach so.
Sex attract.
Nee, wirklich nicht.
Können wir das Ganze an Anfang schneiden, damit die Leute denken, solche intimen Details kommen häufiger? Genau, darauf geht es unsere Überschrift.
Larissa Ries hat noch nie einen Orgasmus vorgetäuscht.
Nee.
Clickbaiting.
Ja.
Wimma, ist du eigentlich gerade eine Tür?
Wimma, du Fotze, komm jetzt Ja. Wimma, isst du eigentlich gerade eine Tür? Wilma, du Fotze, komm jetzt her. Wilma, komm her jetzt. Hier. Jetzt schlägt sie ihren Hund. Ich weiss nicht, ob das sein muss. Aber nicht so dollwürgen. Was machst du denn? Dieser Star schlägt seinen Hund. Willst du einen Schokobon? Willst du wirklich keinen Schokobon? Nee, ich möchte keinen Schokobon, weil du die Schokobon irgendwo aus den letzten Eckenweilung... Für jeden Schokobon, den du nicht isst, kriegt Wilma jetzt einen Schokobon.
Aber ich hätte doch gern mein Wasserchen, ist Lea.
Warum willst du meinen Schokobon nicht nur, weil ich ihn aus der Hosentasche gezogen habe? Jetzt gibt's den Schokobon, komm, das ist jetzt wie eine Mutprobe für mich.
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Hm, danke schön.
Ja, das wäre sehr nett.
Das ist ein gutes Schokobon.
Danke.
Die besseren Gags werden von jemandem gemacht, der kein Mikro hat in diesem Raum. Das ist ein bisschen wie diese Bowling for Columbine Szene, wo dieser Schüler einfach 30 Waffen überall aus seinem Körper rauszieht und so ganz viele Waffen auf den Tisch legt. So ist es mit Süßigkeiten. Ich habe noch ein paar, weil weisst du nämlich, wie das... Boah, das ist denn im Bowling for Columbine, an welcher Stelle? Im Bowling for Columbine, da wird gezeigt, wie man sich durch diese Sicherheitsüberprüfstellen bei Schulen schleusen kann. Und dann kommt dann so ein Schüler so und er sieht halt ganz normal... Bei Schulen? Bei Schulen, ja, da ging es ja um so diese Amokläufe. Nie gesehen. Bowling for Columbine. Nie gesehen. Und er dann sagt, er so, ja, du siehst ja nicht so aus, als hättest du Waffen. Und dann holt er halt wirklich auch aus seinen Beinen, aus seinen Hosenbeinen, wie so Shotgun raus, einfach wie so riesengroße Sachen. Das ist eine krass Szene. Ich meine, wir haben da oft schon mal drüber gesprochen in diesem Podcast. Es gibt ja diese Filmszenen immer, wo jemand eine Waffe rausholt und dann steht da jemand vor ihm und sagt, ja, deine andere auch noch und dann holt er noch eine Waffe raus. Wo ich mich immer frage, wie awkward wäre das, wenn der echt keine Waffe mehr hat?
Und wenn man einfach, also wenn man dann wirklich fragt und dann andere auch noch, ja ich habe keine mehr, ich meine, es könnte wirklich dann auch extrem awkward enden, wenn der dann wirklich keine Waffe mehr hat.
Woher weiss derjenige immer, dass er noch eine Waffe hat?
Ja oder wie oft muss man nachfragen, weil die Gangster denken ja mit, die rüsten ja immer mehr auf und am Ende haben sie dann drei versteckte Waffen und irgendwann vier und dann fragt er nur noch fünfmal nach und dann spricht sie das rum und irgendwann laufen die mit so riesigen Knöcheldingern einfach rum und einfach so noch einen, noch einen und dann einfach immer mehr.
Und die Filmszenen werden immer länger und unangenehmer. Leider zwölf Minuten von jedem modernen Actionfilm sind nur diese Waffen bereit. Waffengehorror. Ja, das ist wie mit den Touristen in New York, die immer fünf extra Brieftaschen dabei
haben müssen, weil die Räuber genau wissen, dass sie Fake-Brieftaschen haben.
Das heisst, du musst immer eine mehr haben, als der Räuber denkt, dass du hast. Wir waren ja in New York. Ja, weil der Räuber liest ja auch den Reiseführer, in dem steht, hab immer eine Fake-Brieftasche dabei. Deswegen fragt er noch nach einer zweiten. Und um aufzurüsten, immer drei, immer mehr. Wunderbar hat sich die Portmolik geklaut. Nein, überhaupt nicht. Und so auch nichts passiert. Wo wir in Harlem waren. Er hat acht Stück und alle acht sind noch so. Wir sind alle acht noch da. Wir wurden angeschossen, aber es wurde nicht getroffen. Ich habe jetzt sogar neun aus irgendeinem. Wir haben zum Glück schlechte Schützen. Das war unser Vorteil. Ich habe sogar eine Brieftasche mehr mittlerweile mitgenommen, als ich hingekommen bin, weil ich angefangen habe, Leute auszurauben. Weil in Harlem wird man dann auch einfach kriminell. Ja, glaube ich. Die Luft, das ist einfach. Die Häusenstamm. Ja, das ist ein bisschen Spirit, Harlem Spirit. Zurück zu dir. Das Baguette wurde ja von französischen Soldaten erfunden, um sie sich in die Hosenbeine zu schieben. Ach, weil die hatten so viel Ausrüstung, als sie unter Napoleon nach Russland gezogen sind, weil die so viele Kleidung mitnehmen mussten, weil es da so kalt war. In Russland ist es kalt. Und deswegen hatten die keinen Platz mehr in den Rucksäcken und haben gesagt, fuck, wir brauchen ja noch Proviant und haben dann Brote gebacken, die man sich in die Hosenbeine schieben kann. Was ich hier alles lerne an so einem bescheidenen Feiertag. Das war, glaube ich, das einzige, was du bist. Ach nee, Fron Leichnam haben wir auch erklärt. Nee, hast du es nicht erklärt. Du hast es nur gesagt, dass... Du hast es nur gesagt, dass... Also Fron Leichnam, das ist dieses, das kommt, das macht gar keinen Sinn. Ja, warum nicht? Ja, weiter habe ich nicht gelesen. Weiter habe ich nicht gelesen. Ja, ich glaube, das ist um die Eucharistie in der Sakristei. Ja, ja. Was glaubst du eigentlich, wann wird der nächste Feiertag eingeführt und welcher wird er sein? Also es gibt ja irgendwann immer wieder neue Feiertage und alte Feiertage. Die Frage ist, wann war denn der letzte und was war der letzte? Deutsche Einheit? Independence Day, als sie erst wieder die Aliens besiegt haben und dann der Independence Day. Helms Klamm, Schlacht um Helms Klamm, sowas in der Art. Aber eigentlich, Tag der deutschen Arbeit müsste eigentlich der letzte sein. Kann nur sein, ja. 9. Mai, aber was ist der nächste? Wann ist wieder so ein Tag und man sagt, Alter, jetzt aber. Ich glaube, Rockstar sein neues Album rausbringt. Das wird, ja. Kommt's, eins in Arbeit? So schlecht. Ich wüsste jetzt nicht. Was hast du gerade dein Zehner-Knöppelblick da drüben so? Ist da was in Arbeit? Da ist mir da etwas noch im Köcher, ein Fall? Wo kommen die Moderationskarten her? Ich habe mich immer gedrückt einfach, mit dem Podcast auf Rückseite. Ja, tatsächlich kommt was. Geil! Irgendwann. Das ist total exklusiv. Ja, weiss keiner. Mega gut. Eigentlich habe ich offiziell gesagt, ich mache keine Musik mehr, es kommt wieder was. Ach, geil! Wow! Wie sieht so ein kreativer Prozess aus? Liegt man in der Badewanne und denkt sich, mein Gott, bin ich genial, da muss mal wieder was kommen? Oder sitzt du am Schreibtisch und schwitzt oder sitzt du in... Ich bin tatsächlich... Das Schlimme ist, dass ich... Wo sitzt du? Wo ich sitze, beim Schreiben oder beim Ausdenken. Genau. Den Grundstein liege ich immer viel beim Autofahren. Ich fahre mega gerne Auto und überlege mir Sachen dabei. Ich fahre manchmal einfach weit weg und dann fahre ich wieder zurück. Und was hörst du dabei? Radio, Musik, Klassik? Musik. Das ist ein bisschen diese auf dem Land aufgewachsene Romantik des Autofahrens, oder? Kann das sein?
Ja, muss ja. Traktor oder Automersen.
Kenn ich aber auch, ich fahr auch gerne Auto. Ich glaube, das ist eher was von ...
Also, Großstadtleute haben das gar nicht so. Das ist eher Nerv.
Bist du eigentlich auch so ein Vorstadt-Kid wie ich, oder was?
Ja, sowas. Vom München Richtung.
Minger.
Es gibt Gorschlichts Bier nicht, weil jeder Bier ...
Ja, ist ja gut. Du kannst nicht. Ich hab einen Satz von ihm gelernt. Aber du hast gar kein Auto flogen, oder? Nee. Aber das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr Bier nicht, weil jeder Bier... Ja, ist ja gut. Du kannst es nicht. Ich habe einen Satz von ihm gelernt. Aber du hast gar kein Auto vorhin, oder? Nee. Aber mit dem Auto mit der Eltern dann immer... Vermisst du das dann, rumzufahren damit? Ja. Also du bist gar nicht selber gefahren, du liebst einfach nur gefahren zu werden. Nee, mit dem Auto meiner Eltern zu fahren. Den Kopf so aus dem Fenster zu strecken, im Fahrtwind. Und auf dem Kofferraum. Ach so geil. Hast du einen Führerschein? Ja. Gut.
Wir haben das gerade verschämt in deiner Hand, was ist daran peinlich, einen Führerschein zu haben. Mein Gott, ich habe einfach nur überlegt, ob das alle Menschen haben, diese Romantik des Autofahrens,
oder nur Leute, die es halt mit ihrer Kindheit verbinden, mit den endlos wirkenden Landstrassen,
wo man dann endlich zur Party kommt.
Manuelsen hat das auch. Kennt ihr Manuelsen?
Nee, kenne ich nicht Manuelsen.
Der Maler? Ja, der grosse Maler da Manuel Elsen, der Komponist. Gut, dann macht's keinen Sinn. Der ist ganz toll. So ein schwarzer Rapper aus dem Pot. Aber wie sieht es aus? Der verleiht immer Stellverbote. Setzt du dir eine Deadline, bis zu dem Tag muss ein Song fertig sein, oder machst du einfach drauf los und es liegt dann acht Jahre lang lieben? Ich bin mega der, ich glaube, ich habe kein grösseres, also ich könnte nie ein Buch schreiben wie Kribbeln im Kopf, weil es wäre einfach nur so, ich weiss auch nicht, was ich da mache, tschüss, mega kurz und dumm, ich kann dir nicht erzählen, wie kreative Prozesse ist. Aber du kriegst halt aber, ist nicht der wahre kreative Prozess, seinen Arsch hochzubekommen einfach? Das ist es tatsächlich und konzentriert bleiben, weil ich bin da so ein, ich bin, wenn ich, ich habe manchmal das Problem, ich denke da ganz ganz lange und auf einmal stehe ich in der Küche und also ich merke das gar nicht. Wieder vom Kühlschrank, wieder knibbelst du die Babybells auf, die Babybells, aber die blauen Babybells. Ja, die Sandwich-Kälen. Bei mir war neulich beim Babybell so eine kleine Schaufel dabei. Ja genau, in die Mikrowelle, damit der Käse schmilzt, dann kannst du so rausgesen. Das ist die beste Idee, ich hab mich schon oft gedacht, wie geil würde ich jetzt ein Babybell im Mikrowelle. Oft sah ich in einer Firma und dachte mir, jetzt ein Babybell im Mikrowelle. Aber kann man Gaula überhaupt gut schmelzen? Ja! Wirklich? Ja! Ich habe es nicht probiert, ich habe mich nicht getraut. Draussen scheint ein Baby. Ja, es ist Produktions-Baby. Jetzt haben alle Mitarbeiter zusammen kreiert im 3D-Druckerer. Jetzt ist sie draußen in die Freiheit entlassen. Radio Nikola ist relativ erfolgreich. Wir wollen jetzt auch bei Patreon richtig durchstarten. Hast du Tipps? Man macht sich eine Patreon-Seite. Okay, haben wir. Wie kommen wir so in den Podcast-Olymp? Ihr wurdet zweimal ausgezeichnet von iTunes als das beste Podcast. Beste 2015. Aber da sind ja ganz viele komische Leute. Wer macht das denn?
Du kennst die Leute, die das machen bestimmt.
Ich kenne da gar keinen. Ach, ich finde das immer ganz interessant. Ich weiß noch gar nicht, wie das alles überhaupt passiert ist.
Ihr wart doch auch schon Platz eins und sowas. Ihr seid doch auch mega.
Ja, aber der finanzielle Erfolg bleibt noch raus. Klar, wir haben das Prestige, wir haben den Respekt, wir haben die Likes, aber wir haben nicht das Geld. Das fehlt noch. Dann müsst ihr jetzt einfach Patreon aufmachen, ein bisschen geile Milestones reinpacken, Leuten ein bisschen was bieten. Nachlesen sind wichtig. Wir machen zum Beispiel immer Nachlesen. Es gibt zum Beispiel eine ganze, ich mache dann zum Medienpodcast, rede ich nochmal 45 alleine, nochmal 45 Minuten alleine. Das ist dann halt exklusiv, die Leute brauchen ein bisschen exklusiv, wir müssen ein bisschen exklusiv. Ah, exklusiver Content verstehen. Ah, also eine Nachbesprechung quasi von der Folge, was dann wieder in der eigenen Folge. Ja, sozusagen. Aber das ist halt, die Leute haben das Grundzeug, und dann haben sie noch ein bisschen neben Häppchen-Zeug. Der Mädchen-Podcast war sehr gut. Ich glaube, das ist wirklich einer der legendären Einzel-Podcast-Folgen in der deutschen Podcast-Geschichte eigentlich.
Also das hört man immer wieder,
dass das irgendwie so ein krasses Ding war.
Und es war auch krass einfach.
Es war ewig lang, aber total krass,
sehr intim, privat, also mega gut.
Aber wirklich, es gibt ja auch legendäre Podcasts
mittlerweile schon im Deutschen.
Aber so einzelne Folgen, die man in zehn Jahren
noch in allen die besten Folgen aller Zeiten
in Listen finden wird, war echt
Mädchen-Podcast einer der wenigen. Und habt ihr nur über Mädchen gesprochen, eure Mädchen-Geschichten quasi? Das haben wir auch schon mal. Der war eine Minute lang. Wir hatten Essens-Podcast und Mädchen-Podcast. Wir haben gesagt, wenn der Essens-Podcast länger ist als der Mädchen-Podcast, dann ist das falsch. Und der Essens-Podcast ging fünf Stunden und der Mädchen-Podcast ging sechseinhalb. Wurde er noch mit Benny Borg gestreckt, aber es war tatsächlich über sechs, es war gut. Und Adam Sandler ging sechs Stunden. Also Adam Sandler war sehr nah an den Mädchen dran. Wir haben mehr Geschichten hier. Aber sechs Stunden nehmt er dann auf? Wie zur Hölle riecht er das hin? Also ich meine, so allein konzentrationsmäßig. Also für mich war ab der Hälfte alles neu, weil er hatte eine Flasche Grasovka drin irgendwann. Wir nehmen ja alle nicht nehmen ja nicht so schön auf wie ihr hier so im schönen Ambiente, sondern wir sitzen ja alle alle einzeln in unseren Podcast-Zimmern, tragen keine Hosen. Das ist das Geheimnis. Und dann Skype und dann wird das alles halt, jeder nimmt seine Spur einzeln auf und dann schicken wir alles zu Dominik und er muss es schneiden. Synchronisiert ihr auch mit einem Klatscher am Anfang? Ja. Alle klatschen gleichzeitig einmal. Ne, wir zählen immer fünf, vier, drei und dann zählen wir mal runter. Und das ist immer so, ich habe ja noch den Rumblepack-Podcast und das sind halt die grössten Moos, weil die besitzen keinerlei Taktgefühl für diese fünf, also das funktioniert nie. Da ist immer so fünf, vier, drei und du bist immer so, Mann, Alter, Tim! Wir hatten, das war auch mal im Schulorchester damals, dass irgendwer dann einzählen musste, der aber keine Ahnung hat von Taktgefühl. Dann wie eins, zwei, drei, eins, zwei, drei und dann haben wir alle angefangen, alle haben unterschiedlich. Eins, zwei, eins, zwei, drei, vier und dann haben alle aber was anderes gespielt, andere Songs auch einfach, weil die so verwirrt waren. Warum lässt man so einen dann einzählen, das verstehe ich dann auch nicht. Wir haben schon alles versucht, weil ich das auch oft die Situation hatte, dass wir nicht im gleichen Raum waren und wie man es synchronisieren kann, und wir hatten glaube ich schon die Idee über eine Atomuhr, dass wir beide die gleiche, dass wir beide die gleiche auf Uhr.de Uhr.de! Ja, auf Uhr.de! Uhrzeit.net oder so ist mittlerweile. Ja, mittlerweile ist die eine andere Formel geholt, weil wir nicht überrannt haben, weil dass wir dann wirklich da die die gleiche Uhr haben und dann die runterzählen oder so, dass wir wirklich synchron sind. Es könnte mir eher clever sein, aber leider ist mein Garage-Band, damit machen wir das, manchmal mit Paint nehmen wir auch auf, ganz langsam so, und das dauert halt immer ein bisschen, bis es dann anfängt aufzunehmen, aber hat nicht funktioniert richtig. Ja, und es gab einen Delay deswegen, aber es ist so technischer Blabla, das versteht ihr ihr keine. Lass uns lieber über Essen reden, über Schokobons reden. Über Schokobons, ich habe den jetzt wirklich gegessen, Florian. Und war ja schlechter als ein normaler Schokobons, der war ganz geil, oder? Ich glaube, da hast du bestimmt vergiftet oder das, weil ihr wollt die Konkurrenz ausschalten nach und nach, ich weiß, ihr lockt die jetzt alle her. Ach so, und dann wird vergiftet in Schokobons. Ja, und dann übernimmst du unser Paydon. Ah. Wo geht das Geld, wo würde das Geld hingehen, wenn ihr alles sterbt? Auf meinem Paypal-Konto. SOS Kinder. Ja, SOS, SOS. Die nehmen sich immer alles sofort, einfach sobald jemand stirbt. SOS, hallo, hallo, ja, hallo, das gehört den Kindern, meine Herren, her damit. Das heißt ja, SOS Kinderdorf, wie viel Geld wollen die noch haben, damit aus Kinderdorf jemand eine Stadt wird? Es wird einfach so eine sehr high-tech Stadt.
Es wird aber eigentlich ein Erwachsenendorf auch gewohnt.
Das klingt doch immer, Kinderdorf klingt immer so, als hätte man einfach so wie so ein Fort gebaut,
was nur so aus so Holz stehen bestellt wurde.
Kinderbürgermeister.
Und alle sind so angezogen, so wie bei The Revenant und so.
Kinderbürgerkrieg einfach.
Die grossen Kinderbürgerkriege von 2003 Jahren.
Das ist hausparkmässige Szenarien.
Ja, das stimmt, nur Kinder.
Das ist nicht schlecht. Das ist, glaube ich, lustig. Ein Sketch. Mal da mal was. Mal da mal was. Ja. Und ja, ansonsten so? Aber, weil eben Schokobons magst du nicht, was dann Lieblingssüßigkeit? Doch, Schokobons sind gut. Lieblingssüßigkeit? Lieblingssüßigkeit, ich finde, weisse Reese's mit, weisse Reese's, diese mit Peanut Butter gefüllten. Die sind mega krass. Und dann noch weisse Schokolade drumherum, und weisse Schokolade ist eh das Beste, finde ich. Die sind ja von Hershey's, ne, und es gibt in USA, waren wir im Hershey's World, glaube ich. Das ist einfach eine Welt, die nur aus Süssigkeiten von Hershey's besteht. Es gibt Hershey Bürgermeister, Hershey, Hershey. Alles auch nur Kinder, seltsam aber was. Auch alles vom Essen als Kinder drauf gebaut. Ja. Ist aber direkt gegenüber von der M&M World.
Die M&M World war ich auch mal in London. Ich finde, das ist der absurdeste Laden, in dem ich je war. Du hast sechs Stockwerke oder so, nur mit M&M Sachen. Es gibt alles, es gibt von Golfschläger Schützen, auch der Golfschläger, es gibt Golfbälle, es gibt hunderttausende von T-Shirts, es gibt eine Star Wars Meets, Was, Melz ... Ich hatte so ein T-Shirt, da war dann so ein M&M in Karbonit gegossen und stand It melts in your Haaren. It melts not in your Haaren und du bist so, Alter, okay, crazy, Alter. Und tausende von Sachen. Aber wer ist denn M&Ms Fan? Keiner M&Ms Fan. Es ist auch willkürlich, welche Gegenstände dann als Merch benutzt werden. Da war zum Beispiel so ein Backhandschuh, ein M&M's Backhandschuh. Ja. So, warum genau das und nicht eine Zahnbürste? Wer entscheidet das denn genau, was jetzt dazu passt und was nicht? Das ist so willkürlich einfach. Wenn mir jemand gesagt hätte, wie stellst du die M&M World vor, dachte ich, ich werde einfach so ein ganz, ganz kleiner Laden, die halt jeden M&M einmal haben oder so. Ja, aber die M&M World ist ja eigentlich relativ begrenzt, weil es sind ja einfach nur kleine Schokodinger. Ja, schon, und es gibt halt diese blöden Dinger, die so, hey, die man aus der Werbung kennt, die sind mit den Gesichtern drauf. Aber das ist ja keine so kultige Marke, dass du da raus... Also Disney ist eine Marke, aus der du ein Sechstück ins Dorf filmst. Der Fruchtiger, das sind Charaktere. Flutschfinger, Ferdifuchs. So was, ja. Ferdifuchs-Paradies. Es gibt echt viele Füchse auch. Es gibt Sparfuchs, Spefuchs, dann den Wüstenrot-Fuchs, Ferdi-Fuchs. Es gibt überraschend viele Füchse. Fuchs, Megan Fox. Ja. Auto, VW-Fox. Jetzt wird es albern. Fox-Trotz? Es gibt wirklich einen VW-Fox. Ähm, ja. Fällt dir noch einen Fox ein? Ja, nicht zugehört. Okay. Alles klar. Wie lange nehmt ihr mal auf? Acht Stunden ungefähr. Zwölf bis siebzehn Stunden. Okay, wir nehmen mal eine Stunde auf. Je nach Zeit. Wollen Leute das hören? Also das ist egal. Also ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen, was denn? so einen ganzen Podcast, also so siebzehn Stunden lang Podcasts zu hören, ist schon hart, glaube ich. Wir hatten jetzt zu letztens einen 24-Stunden-Stream-Dokular, das waren einfach Leute, die waren einfach 24 Stunden von vorne bis hinten da. Nachts waren wir eigentlich nur noch von der, irgendwann ist Gön schlafen gegangen. Gön schläft halt immer so, dass er sich einfach irgendwo auf den Stuhl setzt und legt seinen Kopf auf den Tisch und dann bleibt er einfach vier Stunden in dieser Position. Er lebt dann wieder auf der Tod einfach. Er ist einfach, manchmal hofft man es, aber das war nicht so. Und naja, auf jeden Fall bestand die ganze Nacht dann eigentlich nur daraus, dass wir auf Pearl.de waren. Kennt ihr Pearl.de? Nee. Ich glaube, das ist die schäbigste Seite im Internet. Ist das die Drumfirma, Pearl? Hm? Pearl-Schlagzeuge? Nee, die machen so Dings, die haben so ganz viel Trash, die haben ganz viel mit LEDs. Also eigentlich gibt's bei Pearl alles, was mit LEDs hat, kriegst du da. Da gibt's auch so kleine Saunen, aber nicht so Saunen, wo du dich ein bisschen Kopf drin einstest, sondern wirklich kleine Holzeine. Die sehen aus wie ein Smart, man kann sich reinsetzen, eine Tür und dann ist eine Einmann-Sauna. Das haben wir uns die ganze Nacht einfach angeguckt, Sachen auf Pearl, die haben das einfach kommentiert, vier Stunden. Das war eigentlich das Highlight für die Leute. Und selbst da waren immer noch, also es waren acht oder neunhundert Leute, waren konsequent von Anfang bis Start an, der Rest war halt dann so fliegend.
Das ist schon absurd, ich bin manchmal auf YouNow unterwegs, du weißt, ob du das kennst, so was wie YouTube sehr populär, nur halt für Streamer, die halt den ganzen Tag streamen und halt wirklich nur labern, also nicht qualitativ hochwertig, sondern einfach nur in die Kamera labern. Und da gibt es wirklich manche Streamer, die einfach so lange streamen, dass sie sich teilweise auch beim Schlafen filmen.
Die streamen einfach, labern und so, oh, bin ich müde, leg mich hin.
Und dann drehen die ihre Kamera so, dass man das Bett auch beim Schlafen filmen. Die streamen einfach, labern und so, oh, bin ich müde, lege mich hin und dann drehen die ihre Kamera so, dass man sie auf dem, dass man das Bett sieht, dann legen die sich so ins Bett und schlafen, will ich so direkt in die Fresse einfach und schlafen die einfach vier Stunden lang, wachen sie desorientiert auf und streamen direkt weiter so, das ist so absurd. Wie einsam musst du denn sein, wenn das deine Hauptbeschäftigung ist? Es ist so seltsam und es lustig ist, mein... Das sagen die Leute, glaube ich, auch über Podcasts. Ja, wahrscheinlich, ja, aber ich glaube, Streamer sind noch eine Stufe drunter. Und Lars Pausen, ein Freund von mir, der hat auch mal auf YouNow gestreamt, der hatte so eine YouTube-Show und hat das Making-of auf YouNow gestreamt und da hat er irgendwann mal so, da kannst du auch Geld verdienen, da können die den Zuschauer Geld spenden und der hat einmal irgendwie so 90 Dollar bekommen oder so auf einmal und so und das war irgendwie total krass und da war er auch gerade in Kontakt mit so einer YouNow Representative Person, die auch will, dass da nicht nur irgendwie Leute masturbieren und so und auch so Conan ist und da meinte sie, ja, ja, das kann mir mal passieren und zwar gibt es da relativ viele Scheiche in Saudi-Arabien, die auf YouNow sich blonde Menschen anschauen und dann Geld spenden. Ja, und wir haben uns überlegt, wir lassen uns mal... Einfach nur blonde Menschen an, weil sie blond sind. Ja, und wir haben uns überlegt, wir lassen uns die Haare mal blond färben einfach. Für. Auch für YouNow. Das ist, glaube ich, das Geilste für Leute, die blonde Leute lieben. Ja, aber wir gucken, wie Leute blond werden. Ist nicht das das grosse Geheimnis eigentlich, dass wir immer versuchen, wir wollen immer nur den armen kleinen Mann ansprechen, aber wir müssen da hin, wo es das Geld ist, wir müssen die Scheiche ansprechen. Absolut, absolut. Wir müssen mal gucken, dass wir da das Geld abholen, weil die wollen uns. Ich war einmal im Casino, als ich 18 wurde, in Berlin, und dann habe ich halt für 10 Euro Chips geholt, habe immer auf Rot und Schwarz gesetzt. Gleichzeitig, oder was? Gleichzeitig, was ein bisschen blöd war. Und dann nebenan waren halt immer so reiche Menschen, die immer so 50, so riesen 50 Tausender Chips, die so Gold waren und geglitzert haben und so einen Scheiß, haben die einfach auf eine Zahl immer gesetzt. Und ich mir dachte, wenn du nett zu denen bist und denen einfach einen lustigen Gag erzählt oder so und den richtigen Moment erwischt, geben die die vielleicht einfach 50.000 Euro. Ich glaube, du könntest Leben davon, wenn du ein mega charmeiter Typ bist und ein mega zugänglicher Socializer bist, könntest du einfach davon leben, im Casino zu sein und mit reichen Leuten zu sprechen. Man muss die Leute erreichen. Ja, das stimmt schon. Mein Bruder arbeitet als Schuhverkäufer und da kommen auch manchmal sehr reiche Russen auch so vorbei, die dann einfach ihre Frauen dann irgendwie hundert Schuhe kaufen und so. Und der kriegt Trinkgeld auch einfach nur in, der Typ greift einfach in seine Hosentasche und gibt dir was da drin ist. Und da kannst du halt manchmal so Fussel. Wie bei dir dann Kinder Schoko-Punks. Also Pokémon-Karten und so. Aber das sind halt manchmal 15 Euro und manchmal halt irgendwie 3000 Euro einfach, die er einfach mit einer Hand einfach hier, die er einfach alles gibt.
Wie viel?
3000 Euro oder so, einfach je nachdem, wie viel er halt dran ist.
Wäre es schon mal passiert, als er 3000 Euro bekommen hat?
Ja klar, wenn du einfach Geld dran ist.
Die heben halt irgendwie krassen Scheiss ab, den sie sich in die Hosen lasst und gehen dann durch die Nacht und so und wenn du halt Glück hast, dann ist halt richtig viel Geld dabei.
Mit der Geldklammer.
Ja, dann hast du es geschafft.
Von der Geldklammer.
Auf jeden Fall.
Wenn du Geldklammer hast, hast du es geschafft.
Aber Geldklammern sind auch nur möglich, wenn du eine geile Währung hast. Nämlich kein Kleingeld und nur Schein. Kein Münzgeld, keine Cents. Ich habe ein Riesenproblem mit Münzen. Und jetzt haben die die 5-Euro-Münze rausgebracht, und das ist das Gegenteil von dem, was ich mir in Zukunft vorstelle. Direkt ein Schlag ins Gesicht von Stefan Titzel. Ich habe mich drei Tage lang wachgelegen, als ich herauskam, dass die 5-Euro-Münze rauskam, mit einem Plastikring. Er hat ein Plastikverstand vorhin, die Leute offensichtlich. Ist die schon da? Ja, das ist so ein Dimmigteil, das ist keine normale Währung, das ist so wie die 10-Mark-Münze damals. Die 10-Mark-Münze? Ich habe immer gelesen, dass es damals offensichtlich ein Eklat gab, als der Euro kam, weil Leute verunsichert waren, steht dann in diesem Artikel, Leute waren verunsichert, weil es keine 5-D-Mark-Pendant gab, es gab keine 5-Euro-Münze damals. Und dann sind Leute verunsichert rumgelaufen. Die dachten, da müssen die Münzen einzeln umgeben. Wie ist das auch? Warum sind Leute verunsichert, weil sowas nicht mehr da ist? Und dann ist es noch nicht so schwer umzudenken. Wie so ein Sims, der einfach so verwirrt in der Wohnung rum war. Immer nur so an die Wand, so ein Ripping-Spieler. Wenn man eine Sims in den Pool geschickt hat und dann die Leiter rausgenommen hat. Ja, genau. Die grausamste Art. Ihr kommt da raus, ihr müsst nicht sterben, genau. Genau so sind hier noch rumgelaufen. Keine fünf Mark-Münze, was mache ich jetzt? Keine Chance. Das war nicht sehr lustig, die Vorstellung. Das war damals auch für alle sehr irritierend. Da haben die Leute immer diese Säckchen, da war das noch ein richtiges Event, wann war das 2001 auf zwei? Ja, kann sein, ich habe auch noch ein Säckchen. Aber das war, man denkt sich ja manchmal, so wenn ich irgendwie als Kind irgendwie so noch so eine uralte Lego-Raumschiffbox oder so gekauft hätte und nicht aufgemacht hätte, wäre die heute irgendwie das dreifache wert oder so. Aber man muss ja auch irgendwann diesen Gedanken fassen und sagen, okay, jetzt kaufe ich was, damit es in zwanzig Jahren viel wert ist. Also irgendwann, man kann ja auch rückwirkend an diesen Moment erschaffen, einfach jetzt sagen jetzt. Aber man kauft es sich ja nur, weil man da auch Bock drauf hat. Ich habe mir jetzt ein Lichtschwert gekauft. Okay, das ist ein Fehlkauf, Stefan. Aber es ist wirklich... Du hast ein Lichtschwert gekauft, jetzt halt mal das Maul vor. Was hast du für ein Lichtschwert gekauft? Die Replika aus Episode 4 von Lukes Lichtschwert und, also was da zu Lukes Lichtschwert wird, das habe ich mir geholt, von Hasbro gibt es diese Master Replica Serie. Ja, die Black Series. Genau, und das ist echt ziemlich geil und da habe ich auch überlegt, ich habe es sehr billig bekommen, ich hätte es einfach zulassen können, er hätte es bestimmt, also hätte er auch, er hätte es am nächsten Tag verkaufen können, hätte er 100 Euro Gewinn gemacht, weil ich es ersteigert habe, seltsamerweise. Und das macht man dann nicht, weil man es dann durch die Auspacken will und wie ein Volltrottel durch die Wohnung rennen will mit einem Lichtschwert in der Hand. Ich habe jetzt auch das Ding, ich habe jetzt das Kylo Ren Lichtschwert. Ja, das auch viel cooler ist einfach. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Ich kann mich noch nicht daran anfreunden, so richtig. Was, fandst du Episode 7 nicht so geil? Es schwankt so, es ist so sinusförmig. Ich rede so gern mit Leuten wie sie mit der 7. Ich auch, es ist so, ich habe auch einen Star Wars Podcast, lustigerweise, der mega unerfolgreich, also will ich nicht drüber reden, aber es ist halt so ein bisschen sinusförmig. Ich fand den am Anfang, habe ich lange drüber nachgedacht, fand den dann ziemlich geil und mittlerweile bin ich so, ach, hätte viel besser passieren können, als es dann im Endeffekt dann doch war. Irgendwie so ein paar vergebene Chancen einfach. Ich glaube, man kann Episode 7 jetzt noch nicht ganz fassen. Ich glaube, es geht einfach, es geht um die Trilogie. Es geht um Rückwerte um die Trilogie und dann, glaube ich, kann man den Platz erst richtig einordnen. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt noch so, man ist mittendrin. Wie habt ihr damals Episode 1 wahrgenommen? Seid ihr Hater? Ne, ich war ein Kind damals, das war es geil. Ich war auch viel zu jung. Man kam die raus in 1999 oder so, ne? 1999 kam der erste. Da war ich acht Jahre alt. So, da kannst du kein Hater sein. Niemand ist mit acht Jahren ein Hater. Ich habe die ganzen Figuren einfach gehabt und geliebt. Nee, ich war 15 und war auch kein Hater. Also ich fand das geil damals. Ich fand das alles, die Figuren waren geil, das war ein schöner, bunter Film. Ich weiss aber auch noch genau, dass ich damals nicht viel verstanden habe. Ich verstehe es heute nicht. Die Storyline ist auch, glaube ich, die grösste Schei-St die je geschrieben wurde in der Star Wars-Sage. Aber ich dachte aus irgendeinem Grund, Qui-Gon Jinn sei der Vater von Luke Skywalker. Und ab dann, mit der Prämisse, wenn du mit der Prämisse in den Saal gehst, wird es schwierig. Ich weiß nicht, warum. Aber du warst sehr traurig, als er gestorben ist. Ich dachte mir so, Moment mal, jetzt ist aber was anders. Wurde auch schon oft gesagt, aber es geht im Endeffekt sehr viel um Obi-Wan und sein ganzes Vermächtnis und wie er die Leute dann den einen verliert und den anderen dann doch noch zur hellen Seite bekehrt und so, indem er auch dann stirbt vor ihm und so weiter. Aber den dann einfach die ganze Zeit in diesem seltsamen Schiff auf Tatooine im Schiff sitzen zu lassen und gar nicht an der Story teilzunehmen, weil diese Idee, wenn man dir bewusst wird, ist es ziemlich lustig eigentlich. Es geht die ganze Zeit nur um ihn, aber wir lassen ihn die ganze Zeit in diesem Scheissschiff. Und seine einzige Aufgabe ist es, diese Blutprobe zu analysieren, wo er einfach auf den Knopf drücken musste. Das ist seine ganze Aufgabe, wow, kann man noch ein bisschen spannender machen in dem Moment. Trifft er mit dem Finger an den Knopf, man weiss es nicht genau. Es ist aber echt so, es gibt in dem Film auch keine Hauptfigur. Das ist auch so ein Ding, es gibt einfach keine Hauptfigur. Anakin taucht irgendwie erst nach 30 Minuten auf. Wäre am ehesten die Hauptfigur. Obi-Wan ist keine Hauptfigur, Quoing-Gon-Gin ist auch nicht die Hauptfigur. Es ist wirklich einfach strange. Und es gab mal so einen Typ, der hat Leute gefragt, so, ja, beschreibt doch mal die Figuren aus Episode 1, ohne auf ihr Aussehen oder ihr das, was sie machen, einzugehen. Beschreibt sie mal, wie sie als Figuren sind. Und das konnte man einfach nicht, weil die einfach so flach und so schal sind und man die einfach nicht als Charakter, Persönlichkeit beschreiben kann. Aber jetzt beschreib mal bitte Karate-Kid ohne die Wörter Karate, sein Aussehen und Kid. Ja, das ist schon sehr schwierig. Aber ich meine, zumindest Han Solo kannst du halt irgendwie beschreiben, wie das ein Draufgänger des Queer-Typs so. King Kong ohne die Wörter Affe und New York. Es ist kein Tabuspiel. Es sollte, mein Gott, was ich mir sagen will, dass die Charaktere halt sehr flach sind und man nicht viel mitkriegt. Mein Gott. Ja, stimmt. Das haben die aber bei Sieben schon schöner gemacht, fand ich. Der war schon wesentlich, der war super aufgeräumt, der hat eine schöne Story, der erzählt sich gut. Ich würde ihn auch gerne, aber ja, ist halt sehr uninspiriert, finde ich. Ja, aber das ist immer die Sache, so was
er ist sehr inspiriert von einer von Episode 4. Ja, sehr, sehr, sehr, ja, ich meine, klar. Aber ich glaube, es braucht das, damit man diese Trilogie rechtfertigen kann für den Fans, damit man jetzt auch ein bisschen exzentrischer werden kann. Es war halt nur Fanservice, da bin ich dem auch dankbar für. Und ich glaube, dass jetzt Ryan Johnson extrem einfach auspacken wird und einfach komplett Dinge macht, wo alle, wo auch sehr viele nicht mehr einverstanden sind. Ich habe so ein paar Screenshots gesehen, so geleakte Szenen, weiß nicht, ob ihr da Bock habt, das zu hören, aber da sind echt crazy Leute dabei, einfach abgefahren aussehen und so komische Alienköpfe haben und das sieht halt auch nicht so aus wie Star Wars, aber da habe ich schon jetzt mehr Bock drauf, als auf alles, was ich jemals von Episode 7 davor gehört habe. Das ist einfach eine andere Welt und also nochmal ein grösseres
Universum. Das ist ja auch geil, fand ich damals, dass man halt nie das Gefühl hatte bei den ersten Episoden, dass man gerade bei Seite eins anfängt, eine Story zu gucken, sondern man das Gefühl hatte, davor ist schon sehr viel passiert und da fang ich einfach an, von dem galaktischen Seen nahe zu sprechen und so, den man noch nie gesehen hat bis dato. Das hat mich damals wahnsinnig gemacht, als ich Wenn ich zum ersten Mal Star-House geguckt habe, bin ich wahnsinnig geworden.
Das ist geil!
Ich bin in die Videothek gefahren, hab mir den ausgeliehen, weil ein Freund von meiner musste jetzt endlich mal gucken, dann habe ich das gemacht, habe mir den VHS damals ausgeliehen, habe den eingelegt, da stand in Episode 4 und ich war so, wo sind denn die anderen drei? Dann bin ich zurückgefahren und habe gesagt, ich brauche noch die anderen drei, und habe gesagt, die gibt's nicht, wie, die gibt's nicht, das muss doch da musste ich mich, da gab's doch kein Google. Ja. Und dann sitzt du da und weißt überhaupt nicht, was du damit machen sollst und drehst einfach mit 14, 15 durch und willst irgendjemanden totschlagen. Aber ganz am Anfang hieß es doch gar nicht Episode 1, es ist ja, also nur Krieg der Sterne, ich kannte immer nur Krieg der Sterne und Episode 4, glaube ich, ist dann auch erst später irgendwie dann reingekommen, die wurden ja auch immer auch vor der grossen Erneuerung nochmal irgendwie abgeändert. Ich bin noch sicher, ab wann... Ich glaube, die wurden erst in Episode 4, als klar war, dass er noch in der Trinode wieder auch raus war. Aber es gab noch mal, es gab so, es gab, das war auf jeden Fall nicht diese Special Edition, weil die habe ich dann im Kino später gesehen, die wurde mit der grossartigen Szene in Jabba's Palast, mit dieser Beyonce-Gesangsszene. Ich glaube, das ist eine der schlimmsten Sachen, die ich mir so mein ganzes Leben gesehen habe. Aber allein, dass man davon spricht, ist doch eigentlich, naja gut. Ich würde gerne sagen, das macht es zu Kunst. Was ich auf der anderen Seite... Ich glaube, Star Wars wird als Gesamtkonzept perfekt, auch wegen den verkorksten Prequels. Das wird einfach die perfekte popkulturelles Machwerk, auch wegen den katastrophalen... Leute streiten sich. Das wird besser sein als alles, was jemals perfekt war. Du sprichst so, als wäre es noch nicht passiert. Finde ich nicht, dass Star Wars eigentlich das Mächtigste ist, was es momentan so gibt? Auf jeden Fall, aber es geht noch weiter. Wir sind ja mittendrin noch. Voll, aber wie lange geht die ganze Sache noch weiter? Ja, es kann jetzt natürlich die Megakommerzialisierung kommen mit irgendwie 100 Spin-Offs, Gedöns. Oder wir werden es erleben. Ich glaube, wir erleben auch das Ende des Super-Elden-Films. Weil das hält sich, glaube ich, auch nicht mehr lange. Genau, auch unsere Theorie, dass wir irgendwann Marvel gegen DC in einem ganz grossen Film einfach, der 19 Stunden geht. Und da sterben alle, da sterben alle, sie sterben. Kommentiert von Podcastern, kommentiert von Das-Podcast-Ufo und Grumble-Pack einfach. Ganz weirde Sache, aber das wird glaube ich passieren irgendwann, weil, ohne Scheiss, also Marvel kann jetzt kompliziert durchdrehen, werden sie, DC wird durchdrehen und im Endeffffekt, was die logische Konsequenz ist, ist auch, dass beide in einem Film gegeneinander kämpfen. Aber bitte nicht so wie der Batman-wie-Superman-Film, der war so schrecklich. Das war das Schlimmste, was ich dieses Jahr im Kino gesehen habe. Ja, aber die, ja. Aber Civil War fand ich super? Nee, den fand ich schlimmer als Batman-wie-Superman. Echt? Da bist du aber der Erste, den ich treffe. Ja, aber ich habe auch die ganze Zeit, das habe ich letzte Woche erzählt, da war ich die ganze Zeit in so einem D-Box Motion Seat, der die ganze Zeit einfach die Bewegungen mitmacht.
Das sind so die ultramodesten Neue, das ist die Zukunft von Kino angeblich.
Nicht im Ernst.
Du willst aber die ganze Zeit, ich war der einzige im Kino, der auf diesem Sitz sass, also mitten im Raum und alle haben normal in den Film geguckt und ich wurde die ganze Zeit so, aber übertrieben, ich habe das die ganze Zeit auch auf der höchsten Stufe gehabt, was rückblickend glaube ich eine falsche Idee war, aber ich wurde die ganze Zeit so übertrieben rumgerückelt die ganze Zeit. Wo war das? Das ist jetzt kein Witz, das gibt es wirklich? Es ist ohne Scheiss in Lünen, in Dortmund. Lünen, Lünen. Das ist bestimmt nur so ein alter Mann, der das immer so, Scheiss, muss ich hier, ne? Ich dachte, dass das nur irgendwie so nach oben oder unten, gleich zu links geht, aber es kann übertrieben ausrasten. Und auch bei den Schwenkern am Anfang, es fing ja dann an, irgendwie Budapest, Berlin und so, dann sind ja diese ganz normalen Establisher über die Stadt, die haben so ein kleiner Schwenk. Und selbst da rasten die völlig aus und schweissen einen so mit, als wäre das irgendwie die grösste Actionszene. Gott, ist das schrecklich. Du bist ja eigentlich auch angeschnallt? Nein, du bist nicht angeschnallt. Was? Ja, in der ersten Runde bin ich einfach aus der Kurve geflogen. Aber das war einfach so nach vorne geworfen worden. Ich habe nichts erwartet und es war wirklich die geilste... Ich konnte mich auf den Film nicht so richtig konzentrieren, habe aber nicht ganz verstanden, die Story. Aber stell dir mal vor, die machen das mit so Horrorfilmen, mit so Jumpscares irgendwie. Da ist es einfach auf einmal zack, du bist einfach direkt aus dem Satz Sitz gew Es beginnt ja mit einer Kampfsszene, der Film, und ich dachte mir, okay, der gewöhne dich bestimmt langsam an, da dann den Fakt, dass du gerade rumgeschleuert wirst. Nein, direkt einfach nach vorne, wie so ein Schleudersitz. Da muss ich erstmal den Platz wieder so. Ja, kein Scheiss, aber ich gucke mir den vielleicht nochmal an. Mir haben viele gesagt, der wäre sehr gut. Klingt auch gerade wirklich so, also ich könnte ihn auch nicht objektiv bewerten, wenn ich so gesessen hätte. Ich weiss auch nicht, ob das alles stimmt oder du dich nicht einfach auf einen anderen Typen draufgesetzt hast oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, wenn ich einfach versucht habe, abzustimmten. Der den Film setzt voll. Ich glaube nicht, dass das so existiert, Stefan, ehrlich gesagt. D-Box Seeds gibt es wirklich unfassbar. Ja, hat man sich jetzt gedacht, 3D ist schon richtig unnötig, wir brauchen noch was unnötig. Ja genau, ich glaube, kurz. Und ich glaube, kurz vorm Geruchskino, glaube ich, ist dann der Höhepunkt genannt. Meinst du, das kommt noch? Ich glaube da fest dran. Ich glaube auch Wasser und so. Wie so 5D-Kinos, zum Beispiel im Moviepark, Bottrop da, wo dann ganz schlimm Wasser spritzt. Ja, da war ich immer 4D-Kino, was allein dimensionsthe hundertprozentig passt, aber auch da, da gab es dann so eine Szene, wo ganz viele Mäuse irgendwie auf der Landwand waren. Ich weiss auch nicht. Ich weiss, was das war, das war hier der Phantasialand, dieser Piratenfilm, oder? Das kann sein, und dann wurden so in dem Kinosaal unten so ganz viele Mäuse durch den Saal gätzt, nein, da wurde dann irgendwas so durchgeschossen, was sich so angefühlt hat, als würden dir so Mäuse... Ja, so Luft im Endeffekt, ganz Luftdruck, ja. Genau, als würden die Mäuse durch den Saargelst. Nein, da wurde irgendwas so durchgeschossen, was sich so angefühlt hat, als würden dir so Mäuse... Ja, so Wasser, also so Luft im Endeffekt, ganz Luftdruck, ja. Genau, als würden dir Mäuse zwischen dem Wein durchlaufen. Und dann gibt es eines, wo so Tauben, so eine Möwe kackt und dann fallen so Wassertropfen und so auf dich runter. Ja? Ja, ja, ganz toll. Weil Möwen scheissen Wasser. Möwen scheissen Wasser. Hätten wir mal konsequent gewesen, wenn man richtig viel, Tag so blitterweise, tonnenweise die Möwenscheisse reinpumpt.
Aber nur auf einen, einfach in der Mitte so zack.
Sie wollten realistisch, die haben sie realistisch und die sind Mäuse, viel Spaß.
Sie sind einfach Mäuse, aber einfach totales Chaos, die verschliessen so die Türen,
dann Leute Mäuse, dann kommt so ein Jaguar.
Und alle Leute sterben und pressen sich gegenseitig auf und ficken und keine Ahnung.
Sechs Dekino-Dimensionensionen, der Hitler noch lebt. Das soll das heißen, vier D, was soll das heißen? Vier D! Ist neben ihm noch frei? Nein. Das war meine Hitler-Impression. Habt ihr denn noch Fragen? Wie schaffst du es mir so lange aufzunehmen? Jetzt bin ich schon fertig, ich schwitze. Ich werde jetzt erst warm, Alter. Wirklich? Voll. Ja, ich glaube, das ist eine andere Dynamik bei uns. Kann länger. Wir wollen einfach direkt abliefern, abliefern, abliefern, abliefern und irgendwann können wir einfach nicht mehr. Und merken dann irgendwann, dass wir es nicht können und ziehen uns dann aus Scham einfach zurück. Wie lange geht bei euch noch mal eine Folge? Eine Stunde. Eine Stunde. Also Stunde ist es ja richtig wert eigentlich. Ne, das ist ja bei uns. Autokino, ich habe jetzt noch den dritten Podcast, weil ich mich sehr langweilig den ganzen Tag. Kann man nur empfehlen, Larissa war auch zu Gast in der letzten Folge. Ja, wir haben uns mit Weiswein betrunken. Ist bei uns in der nächsten Folge zu Gast. Larissa ist jetzt auch fester Bestandteil, wir machen jetzt einmal im Monat noch ein Special. Ah, cool. Kann man auch einfach ankündigen jetzt mal hier. Ich krieg da die exklusiven
Informationen. Narissa und ich haben jetzt einen einstündigen, also mach nochmal ein Format zusätzlich. Also eigentlich rede ich auch noch den ganzen Tag. Oder Snapchat, daraus besteht mein Leben. Redest du, um nicht schweigen zu müssen? Ja, weil sonst ertrage ich meine Stimme im Kopf nicht. Was sagen deine Stimmen im Kopf? Meistens geht's um Essen und Blut.
Und Mädels. Mädel-Podcast. Mädel-Podcast. Mädel-Podcast. Der Madel. Der Madel. Der Madel-Podcast. Der Burschen-Podcast.
Du weisst das, der Fischer-Burschen-Podcast. Über meiste das am Fische-Burschen-Podcast. Ich habe mich die Woche gefragt, ob der, ob Chris Teil irgendwann in seinem nächsten Programm, jetzt ist ja gerade, darf er das, und ob er das nächstes, dann darf sie das. Ah, dann geht es auch noch um Sexismus, sozusagen. Dann kommen ja die Reichskristallnacht. Was? Da sich da mal drum kümmern. Die Reichskristall, oh, da hätte ich Bock drauf, ihn einfach mit so einer Schweinepeitsche durch den Hof zu treiben. Der muss dann auch so einen Abzeichen tragen. War der schon mal bei euch zu Gast seine Freunde von dem? Nein, überhaupt nicht. Okay, wir finden den auch scheisse. Den finden alle scheisse. Aber mal ganz kurz im Ernst, ich finde es sehr toll, dass er ein Wortspiel hinbekommen hat mit seinem Namen. Erstmal großen Respekt, dass er so heisst. Aber will man sich da nicht irgendwie konnotieren mit was Coolem, ich meine so ein Kristall, aber es ist nicht so lustig.
Ein Kristall ist meistens recht unwitzig, aber da haben sie ja viel gemeinsam mit zwei.
Ja, aber auch nicht so geil, also nicht so männlich, es ist halt einfach so, also man sieht nicht so einen Comedian, einen dicken Comedian, der über seine Kinder spricht, sieht man nicht so richtig in dem Kristall.
Und vor allem mit Christ kann man auch mehr machen.
Christus?
Christus zum Beispiel. Christian Bale. Kann man auch viel Google verwirren, einfach so ein bisschen. Moment mal. Christian Bale. Also ein cooler Nachname,
so will ich den nennen als Mittelname. Chin Bale. Christian Bale-Becker. Christian Bale Nacht. Ja. Ja. Ich glaube, wir haben es eigentlich, oder? Wir haben es mit einer Stunde. Wir sind noch fünf Minuten noch. Fünf Minuten noch hin, oder? Ja. Ich mache noch ein bisschen Werbung für dich, für deine Sachen, für Karhardt. Du machst Karglas. Karglas. Ich mache Werbung für Karglas. Karglas repariert. Aber es ist tatsächlich so gewesen, dass ich mal, als ich mir irgendwann in mein altes Auto einen Stein in die Scheibe und während dieser Stein gerade eindrang, hatte ich sofort, es kam die Karglas-Werbung. Das ist überkrass, du sitzt so da und dann fragst du, was machst du? Er sagt, Karglas reparieren, Karglas, tausend aus. So während du den Stein noch im Anflug siehst. Genau so was und dieser Riss ging so, und ich war direkt so, ich muss zu Karglas. Das ist so krass gewesen, das ist wirklich, die haben dein Geuliert und die haben scheisse. Wie der Winter Soldier, einfach direkt imitiert, wenn man das weiß, Steinschlag, oh mein Gott! Aber man hat direkt die mit dem Dieben im Kopf. Wie der Winter Soldier, ja das ist wirklich so. Die Szene habe ich mitbekommen, weil da irgendwie gerade der Sitz kaputt oder so. Der Techniker musste die neue Sicherung reinstecken. Der Typ, der den Sitz geschüttelt hat, war aber kurz auf Toilette. Neues Akku, man muss mich wiederbeleben in der Stelle, weiß ich nicht genau. Dass du auch kurz bewusstlos warst, einfach für die Ausgaben, dass du mit einem Film 20 Minuten verpänt hast. Ich war ja mal mit einem Freund von mir im Kino und wir hatten danach so ein Filmkritikformat, dass wir direkt nach dem Kino nach Hause gegangen sind und dann eine Kamera angemacht haben und über ein Film geredet haben. Und dann saß er da so mit verschwitztem Lächeln so, ah und Florentin, wie hat dir Film gefallen? Ja, ich kann es gut. Ja, wirklich? Ich fand es nicht ein bisschen langweilig?
Nö, warum? Du bist eingeschlafen während des Films.
Ich so, was? Du hast es nicht gemerkt?
Ich habe es nicht gemerkt. Du bist jetzt eingeschlafen, du hast einmal laut geschlacht und ich musste dich wieder wecken.
Und ich habe das nicht gemerkt im Film.
Und es war dieses...
Wie war die Weckaktion?
Nein, das war Saving Mr. Banks, dieser Film mit Walt Disney.
Hat dir gefallen auch.
Hat mir gut gefallen.
Ich fand ihn auch nicht langweilig.
Voll eine langweilige Zwischenfahrt, eine mit der Panthers.
Aber da fragt man sich schon, bei wie vielen Filmen in der Vergangenheit habe ich etwa die Hälfte geschlafen, ohne es zu merken. Bei wie vielen Lieren habe ich den Refrain noch nie gehört, als ich die ganze Zeit eingepäntet bin. Ich wollte noch kurz bei Carglass sagen, den Funfact, dass Carglass in England Autoglas heisst. Ja, total stress. Im Ernst? Ja, wirklich. Autoglass Repairs, Autoglass Exchanges, Autoglass Exchanges, Goodbye, sorry, the lyrics doesn't match, exactly, bye. Es gibt auch Saiten River, das gibt es auch noch in der Amerika. Saiten River? Äh, oder zum Beispiel auch Saitenbacher. Milk. Ach, ah. Ich dachte, wo wir gerade beim populären Radiodiversitäten... Ja, das war schon gut. Mein Gott. War gut, war lustig in einer anderen Dimension. Nee, das war in der vierten Dimension. War einfach wahnsinnig langsam. Der Gag nochmal in einem 4D-Kino anschauen, dann glaube ich, ist das richtig gut in einer anderen Dimension. Warum hat sie das nicht gewiss. Kennst du dieses Stickeralben, wo man dann auch manchmal so Sticker hatte, so Geruchgedöns? Diddelblöcke.
Ich hatte diese leeren Augen. Wofür diese Anerkdote hin? Was mache ich heute Nachmittag Augen einfach? Die sind komplett durch mich durchgeschaut, als würde ich Dänisch sprechen. Aber Panini-Alben hat doch keine Geruchsticker. Nee, aber es gab dann so Special Alben, so die Simpsons-Sticker, da habe ich ganz viel gekauft, wo es dann auch so Specialsticker gab, mit so einem runden Kreis drauf, im Gegensatz zu den eckigen Kreisen, die andere Sticker hatten, und wo man dann irgendwie so drauf rubbeln kann, und dann hat es so gerochen. Und es hat alles da dann irgendwie so... Es gab auch mal so Spielzeugfiguren, die haben auch gestunken. Ja, ja. Die waren so Müllzombies oder so. Ja, genau. Die waren so, kleine Asozialeziale sahen die aus, und die haben auch gerochen wie Asoziale. Die hatten aber alle einen anderen schlimmen Geruch. Wo kann man die sammeln? Wo stellt man die denn hin? Genau, die Bärdiebots Bohnen, wenn die friert, die gibt es ja auch so mit Kotze. Ja, mit Kotze. Das habe ich einmal im Maul gehabt, das ist das Schlimmste auf der ganzen Welt. Wie werden die getestet, schmecken, schmecken die wirklich nach Kotze dann? Die schmecken die nach Kotze. Ja, schon wirklich. Welches arme Schwein sitzt da in einem Institut, wo das entwickelt wird? Ja, aber ich probiere mal, ob die Betty-Botze-Bohnen nach Kotze schmecken. Also wir haben hier 80 verschiedene Kotze-Geschmäcker. Sag mal, welchen der Best für das. Okay, alles klar. Also, klar. Mein Studium ist es mir wert. Okay, bitteschön. Das ist doch schrecklich. Ze. Zehn Euro die Stunde, da. Was war dein beschissenster Job, den du jemals gemacht hast? Ich habe so viel gemacht. Ich habe so Zettelchen immer eingeworfen für so einen Ökoladen bei uns im Rottgau. Da habe ich immer, da habe ich immer als erstes zu den Hochhäusern gelaufen, habe geguckt, was da so los ist. Ah ja, genau, dann konnte man die so schnellfeuermäsen. Da bin ich irgendwann, da ist mir eine Tür auf worden, weil ein Typ, der bitte keine Werbung-Sticker hatte. Und da habe ich dann das eingeworfen, da hat er schon hinter der Tür gewartet, hat er aufgerissen und so, das war nicht da aber, aber dann habe ich wirklich meinen Job verloren, weil dieser alte Mann mich verpetzt hat. Wie gut ist das? Ich habe mir neulich im Keine-Werbung-Bitte-Sticker an meinem Briefkasten gemacht, weil es hat Überhand genommen, die Werbung, und dann wurde der einfach abgerissen und dann hatte ich wieder Werbung drin. Ich bin offensichtlich machtlos gegen Werbung. So, jetzt ist aber Face-off, was ist die nächste Phase? Bitte meine erste Mal keine Werbung, dann drunter bitte meine keine Werbungssicker nicht abreissen. Oder umgekehrte Psychologie, bitte viel Werbung, denn wenn sie nicht verwirrt, dann wissen die nicht was sie machen. Ja, die haben mich einfach abgerissen, da dachte ich mir ja, ich bin offensichtlich machtlos gegen Werbung, also dann habe ich einfach aufgegeben den Streit beigelegt. Das wäre ein geiler Film irgendwie so. Stefan gegen die Werbeindustrie. Der erste Plan scheitert okay aus. Ein Könnens, ein Name. Genauso wie ein Kind, der unbedingt Tänzer werden möchte. Und dann geht er in die Tannenschule und die wurde umgebaut irgendwie. Es ist ein Bioladen und dann ein Film zu Ende so. Tannenschule hat zugemacht, ciao, bis zu Teil zwei, haut rein.
Aber nicht glücklich im Bioladen, dann Teil zwei.
Ich habe auch letztens so Sticker gekauft, das ist total geil.
Hast du den gekauft, ich habe den gemacht einfach.
Ja, deswegen hast du den auch abgerissen, weil du nicht gekauft hast.
Unlizenziert, das kannst du auf gar keinen Fall machen.
Du hast jetzt keine Werbung in deinem Briefkasten, deswegen wusstest du nicht, dass es die gibt. Werbung für Anti-Werbung-Sticker, das ist auch nicht schlecht. Das ist nicht schlecht, weil es landet ja nur bei Leuten, die den noch nicht haben. Nicht haben, Marketing! Das war unsere Marketing-Projekt. Da haben wir doch noch gute Ideen zum Schluss eigentlich. Ja, perfekt. Leider ist dir deine Idee nicht mehr eingefallen, wie man die ganze Welt besser machen kann. Aber das hört ihr dann in der nächsten Folge von Das Podcast Ufo. Sehr gern. Ja, vielen Dank, dass du da warst, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast in deinem dicht bestückten Terminplan. Ja, danke Rockstar. Hört alle, Radio Nukulam ist wahrscheinlich nicht empfehlen, kennt ihr eh alle schon, super gut. Und wenn ihr, wenn ihr nur acht... Kommt wieder auf die Tour. Ja, kommt auf die Tour, Rockstar... Wird noch du auf die Tour. Ihr seid eingeladen. Habe ich vielleicht keine Zeit. Alles nett, danke. Aber... Ja, danke schön. Fandst du das letzte Mal so schlimm?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Ich fand es echt gut, er hat geschwärmt.
Ich fand es echt krass, vor allem wie viele Leute da sind, ey.
Das war echt, wir standen an dieser Schlange und das war schon, es war erst die falsche Schlange, aber das ist nicht so wichtig, Organisation war vielleicht nicht so ideal, aber es war echt schon krass zu sehen, weil man sieht ja auch so die Leute, die kommentieren und so die Zahlen ein bisschen, aber dann wirklich einen vollen Raum zu haben und zu merken, okay, da sind echt Gesichter hinten und nicht nur irgendwie taiwanesische Bots, wie man eigentlich sie eingekauft hat, das war schon krass, das war schon beeindruckend zu sehen, da hatte ich schon Respekt, weil so einfach, glaube ich, wäre ich da nicht auf die Bühne gestolpert, wie du das da gemacht hast. Er war einfach betrunken. Es ist viel Alkohol bei euch doch, ne? Also eigentlich nur bei mir. Dominik hat noch nie Alkohol getrunken.
Er hat einmal ein Glas Bier getrunken, das ist so wie ich nur ein einziges Mal ein Muffin gegessen mit Gras und das ist meine einige Drogenerfahrung. Er hat aber runtergefallen. Und ansonsten bin ich ganz verstanden. Auf die Wiese, deswegen war Gras am Muffin. Achso, den habe ich verstanden. Können wir bitte den Gag noch ausschneiden? Wir haben eben besseren gehabt zum Schluss. Aber danke schön, dass du da warst. Das war eine grosse... Ja, das war... Es ist gut, dass wir immer Themen... Wir haben, glaube ich, hundert Themen angefangen, keines noch zu Ende gebracht. Sehr schön. Das ist unser Ding, das ist unser Alkohol. Wenn ihr nur acht Stunden Zeit habt, hört euch nur den Mädchen-Podcast an, den muss man, glaube ich, gehört haben als Podcast-Fan da draußen. Wenn ihr nur acht Stunden zu neben habt, dann hört euch den Mädchen-Podcast an. Auf jeden Fall. Holt euch ein Delfin, zwei Kopfhörer und schön Mädchen-Podcast durch das Mittelmeer.
Ja, vielen Dank, dass du da warst.
Ich danke euch, dass ich eingeladen bin.
Immer gerne. Bis dann. Danke an Larissa.
Ja, danke, dass ich mich noch eingeladen bin.
Da, tschüss!